And people were like um your sin will
never be forgiven. Uh it's not fair that
you you've seen a lot and then you are
forgiven just like this. Why is it that
when Andrew Tate comes to Islam it's
yeah but he was promiscuous before. Yeah
it's his past. Forgive him. He's
forgotten. They defend him till the
death of him. But when it's the sister
people are telling her oh why you will
not be forgiven. Not not only that it's
unfair. Somebody said it's unfair for
you to be to to have your to have your
sins forgiven.
I am a rever and I was taught how to
pray salah. That means every single time
I pray, the person who told me gets the
reward five times a day from to is. If
you want to support someone like me in
learning salah, then sponsor 10 people
for just £100 this Ramadan. Remember the
prophet peace be upon him said, "Charity
does not decrease wealth. Click the
button and donate
now." One skill separates the winners
from those who get stuck. It's not
intelligence. It's not hard work, but
rather it is confidence. And if you
don't master it, you will always
struggle. However, Muslim mastery can
help you fix this. Go to the link guys
inshallah and develop yourself to be the
best version of yourself with confidence
that will get you to places you could
have never imagined. Go to the link now.
So let's get straight into inshallah. So
there's a clearcut double standard
hypocrisy happening. And I tend to speak
about this. I like to speak about this.
Why? Because at the end of the day
actually I'll be honest with you. I
think I'm one of the whenever there is
yes we need to speak out against it.
That's that's true. There is uh the uh
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said that if you didn't enjoy good and
forbid evil, Allah will get rid of you.
Even if you prostrate, Allah will send.
Yeah. Exactly. You know, we have to
enjoy good and forbid evil. Exactly. So
to me, subhan Allah, it doesn't matter
if it's a man, woman, I don't care. A
lot of people, a lot of friend or foe,
friend or foe, it doesn't matter. A lot
of people have this misconception. I
don't know what they add me in it. And
my track record speaks here as if I only
pick on sisters. I've done more videos
refuting YouTuber brothers than vice
versa. And subhan Allah, this video is
no exception. At the end of the day,
this is the following. We've got Andrew
Tate when he came to Islam and we've got
this Japanese sister who was in the
adult industry. Yeah. But you see two
standards. Yeah. When it comes to Andrew
Tate for come and look, the Sharia
caused us to defend and I was one of
those people that defended him. Yeah.
And I don't regret it. When the Sharia
called us to defend it, we defend. When
the Sharia calls us to warn, we warn.
But the thing is I'm consistent. when it
came to for example the Japanese sister
I didn't come and say oh no but her sins
are this that we have to be consistent
why is it that I think it's mainly
brothers why is it that when Andrew Tate
comes to Islam it's yeah but he was
promiscuous before yeah it's his past
forgive him he's forgotten they defend
him till the death of him but when it's
the sister people are telling her oh why
you will not be forgiven not only that
it's unfair somebody said it's unfair
for you to be to to have your to have
your sins forgiven you said
Let's should we watch it? Yeah, let's
show it from her
own. So, since the beginning of Ramadan,
people has been uh commenting about me
sinning before and then people were like
um your sin will never be forgiven. Uh
it's not fair that you s you've seen a
lot and then you are forgiven just like
this or you are not fasting. You are
just creating
content.
Well, I am fasting first of all and
then what Islam told me
is what matters. The only thing which
matter is the intention between me and
God, you and God. So if I am going to
the great place after death or if I my
sin is forgiven or not, it's not matter
to
you. It doesn't matter if my sin is
forgiven or not. If I'm going to the
good place or not, it's not your
mother. So you should be focusing on
your intention between you and God. uh
Allah my intention between me and
Allah is mine and don't you don't need
to care about it I am taking care of my
business I am putting my pure intention
to Allah so do not worry about me please
focus your life please please please
focus on your Ramadan good deeds please
you should be focusing on your life.
Thank you so much Ramadan Barak. Okay,
so actually she's she seems like she's
more on the dean the one that the
criticizing her. She's telling them
don't ruin your Ramadan. Yeah. Try to
try to do good deeds in your Ramadan.
You know, Subhan Allah, she's really
aware. Look, saying that it's between
her and Allah.
No. Whoever seeks repentance, Allah will
forgive him.
Yes. Allah does not forgive.
Yes. Associating partners to him. Yes.
And he forgives what is
exactly and and not only that like
there's double standards. We just have
to the violation that's done against
Allah subhanaa tala. If a woman comes
and says I used to worship 365 different
idols. It's okay. And then another woman
came and said I worship 365. I mean I
slept with 365 men. Oh no. Muslim men
will be like this brother your for the
shik should be greater than your for
yourself. Now it can be we're not saying
you have to marry her. It's a prayer for
a person. You are say it's not for me.
No problem. But you cannot shun her
because you know why? Look at her now.
She look at her repentance. Look this is
sincere repentance. Watch this video
inshallah. And then we're going to
compare that to Andrew Tate cuz she's
been a Muslim for 6 months. Andrew Tate
has been Muslim for over two years. Look
at what she's doing. She's watch it for
ourel this year. The main reason I'm so
excited is to push the journey of my
fate because it's my first RAM and I
have to see like how my body react, how
my body feels and stuff. So,
it's such a special moment for me. I
cannot thank enough for giving me
opportunity to become a better person.
She's she looks more sincere than
Andrew. You know six months she's been a
Muslim. She's in Jb her repentance.
She's not faking that. Yes, you can see
sign. She's fasting the remorse.
But but you know doesn't it remind you
of the of the
the woman the woman who committed you
know at the time of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam and she came
to him and the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam look at his mercy and that said
I want you to cleanse me he said maybe
you didn't said no I want you to cleanse
me so he sent to her because she was
pregnant he sent to her goes go until
you have given birth all of this and she
came back. Then she came back with the
baby. Then I stand to her to suck the
baby. To suckle the baby for two years.
Then she came back. Then she came back
and this time that's it. She asked for
the capital punishment to cleanse
herself. Yes. And once it was a pride,
did the Sahabah say, "What kind of woman
is this? What a disgusting woman. She's
evil. What did the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam say?" Because she was a
woman, he probably shunned her cuz said
that. Was that the case? He said yes by
Allah okay that her blood would suffice
the whole people of Medina. Subhan Allah
her her repentance that one drop of
blood will suffice the whole of Medina
which means what Islam honors woman to
such a degree because what happens in
society is this when she's promiscuous
she's done her repentance they wouldn't
care. Islam says her repentance will
suffice. Meaning she died an honorable
death and and and nobody can come and
speak ill of her. And look look again
another thing here before someone jumps
on the wagon and say oh Islam stoning
and this the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam at the beginning didn't want to
stone her. She is the one that was
persisting in receiving the capital
punishment. She's the one that won. And
guess what? This sister also mentioned
in a video that she been struggling. She
she was praying and she struggled by she
watching all the YouTube videos.
Absolutely. What are we doing here? We
are teaching people how to pray salah
step by step. Inshallah. It's not a
final design, by the way. We're working
it. Yeah. Now, I want you guys to
imagine guys, just a quick in. I just
want to mention this to you guys
quickly. Imagine someone who gets one of
our prayer packs, learns how to do
wudoo, learns how to pray salah, learns
fat, surah, we've got hadith here
telling the importance of these. Yeah.
And every time they do woo. Every time.
Imagine this sister. If we send one out,
it's not incorporated. No, it's not
incorporated. No, the hadith is just to
tell you how important these suras are.
Now imagine if we send one out to the
sister, right? Yeah. And she learns the
entire salah. Every time she prays,
every time she does wudoo, every time
she recites surah faty, the person who
taught her is going to be getting it.
I've been a Muslim for 11 years and the
one who taught me all of this stuff is
banking it. All the deeds that like like
one thing everybody that embraces Islam
everybody that becomes a Muslim and does
all the deeds all his deed goes to the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam your
deed go to the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam my deeds go to the prophet for
him because it is him who who spread the
today is we're in Ramadan it is it's the
night it's the last night and it's the
odd night the odd night may Allah accept
from us a person who's watching this
might want to give £10,000 £10,000 will
teach 1,000 to 3,000 people how to pray.
Well, you know what? Where are we going?
We're going to the holy lands
if somebody if somebody gives
£10,000 to help to help teach 1,000
salah to do on his
behalf on his behalf. I'm jealous for
her behalf. sisters and
brothers behind. Oh, just to explain one
thing. Tell them uh Hajj you do it on
people that can't aren't able to do Hajj
or they are dead. So you do Hajj on on
their behalf. Umra the same thing but
you can do it on behalf of someone even
if they are alive. Even if they are
alive, you can do taw on their behalf
and pray to because every taw has got
but by Allah if someone does give
£10,000 tonight yeah inshallah to teach
we're going to remember a,000 by name to
3,000 people salah even Quran even Quran
and
in seven circumulations of ga I will
circumulate the ka seven times and all
them seven times is just making dua for
this person. All what I'm going to say
is before we go guys for those who have
double standards when it comes to Andrew
Tate and his likes and say sister be
ashamed of yourself. Allah says in the
Quran oh my servants are transgressed
against theirelves do not ever despair
the mercy of your lord indeed Allah is
the one who forgives sins and he's the
most merciful brother and sisters.
Subhan Allah. So guys what I'm going to
say is that's it. Inshallah our religion
is clear and those people I believe a
lot of them are non-Muslims who are
hating trying to push her away. But look
she was expecting Ramadan. Yes. She was
so impatient for Ramadan. Then on the
first day, she's breaking her fast and
she's crying wine
fudah. We're in jilab. Okay. And rotate
in the middle of Ramadan in a nightclub,
then in a casino and eating during
Ramadan. Okay. As I say, I may say she's
a traveler, but the other two, what
excuse? Yeah. Gambling woman party.
Anyway, this sister, subhan Allah, may
Allah bless and preserve her inshallah.
Promise that's what we're going to say.
She'll go for the taw. Yeah, inshallah
for the Let's go. Let's go. Come. We're
going by.